finalement voilà on a un discours qui à
la fin de la fin elle fait un peu acteur
studio c'est à dire de quelqu'un qui a
bien travaillé son rôle mais qu'il
incarne pas totalement
bien quelque chose qui est assez réussie
évidemment c'est la mise en scène
objectivement on a une mise en scène
avec tous les codes de victimes de
droite donc les drapeaux les jeunes
militants le drapeau tricolore
évidemment qui est très prépondérant sur
scène derrière elle même si bien sûr il
ya le drapeau européen mais on voit bien
que c'est ces trois couleurs bleu blanc
rouge elles sont vraiment cottenye
présent sur la scène du zénith
on voit également et c'est un grand
classique des discours politiques et du
meeting politique que elle arrive du
fond de la salle dans un bain de foule
comme pour montrer en effet elle est
portée vers son discours par tout un
ensemble de militants par toute une
salle et qui l'acclament dès le début
c'est un peu joué et parce que le
premier mot c'est bon sens
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes
de métropole des outre mer et de
l'étranger
enfin
enfin nous voici tous réunis
vous m'avez manqué
c'est assez rare de commencer un
discours comme ça par un mot comme ça
isolé et ça fait un peu artificiel c'est
quelque chose qu'on voit beaucoup dans
les concours d'éloquence et c'est vrai
que ce côté enfin comme ça isolé est un
peu et est un peu étonnant et puis d'une
façon générale et dans ce discours il
marche beaucoup pas un certain nombre de
recettes qui marchent très bien dans des
meetings évidemment il y a la recette de
l'anaphore j'accuse j'accuse j'accuse
j'accuse emmanuel macron d'avoir cédé à
la vraie tendance en reprochant à la
france un crime contre l'humanité
qu'elle n'a jamais commis
je l'accuse d'avoir racialisée la
question des banlieues je l'accuse de
vouloir déconstruire notre histoire
je l'accuse d'avoir nié l'existence de
la culture française
évidemment c'est
de la rhétorique
et donc et my soul au coup d'envoi le
dimanche forte de formules qui sont
supposés être choc la france jallet mme
cor est bien
plus la parcours plus je les trains plus
je les trains
puis elle m'émerveille ya un thème qui
est très frappant dans ce discours c'est
l'utilisation du terme de grand
remplacement sort en aux nations unies
où une nation éclaté
face à ces questions vitales pas de
fatalité ni aux grandes et classement ni
au grand remplacement
le terme de grand remplacement il ya
encore quelques mois était à terme
réservé à l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite le radical s'est notamment de
renaud camus qui est donc le créateur de
cette théorie du grand remplacement et
elles étaient donc réservées à cet
extrême noir et en parlant de grand
remplacement et en s'appropriant le
terme est bien elle lui donne valérie
pécresse en quelque sorte les lettres de
noblesse d'un très grand parti d'un
parti qui a des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années derrière lui l'existence je
suis la candidate du travail de la
feuille de paye
souvenez vous nicolas sarkozy avait eu
cette belle intuition travailler plus
pour gagner plus de jacques chirac j'ai
beaucoup appris l'écouté l'empathie mais
aussi et encore l'amour de cette france
de paris et des campagnes mêlée nous
partageons l'amour de la corrèze en
politique j'ai eu aussi une marraine de
coeur
madame simone veil
elle m'a pris sous son aile quand jeune
député je suis arrivé à l'assemblée elle
m'a guidé et soutenu dans mes campagnes
je lui voue une infinie reconnaissance
dans ces trois personnages s'est choisi
de mettre en avant bien bien sûr il ya
nicolas sarkozy dont le soutien lui fait
cruellement défaut même si il le lui
donne mais de façon extrêmement
parcimonieuse bien sûr simone veil et
puis et puis jacques chirac mais là
encore c'est amusant parce que jacques
chirac elle un rock bien sûr la mémoire
de jacques chirac elle essaye de faire
quelque chose de différent elle essaye
de faire quelque chose de puissant site
depuis sincère depuis personnel n'est
malgré tout là encore via la petite
formule très scolaire le set corrèze de
granit et dardoise devenu il ya 27 ans
ma terre d'adoption et donc c'était pas
du tout la corrèze où jacques chirac
était une choré incarner charnelle
physique historique et là encore ça fait
un peu empreint de jacques sur des
figures de style assez classique qui est
la prétérition c'est à dire parler de
quelque chose en disant il paraît que
les familles heureuses n'ont pas
d'histoire alors heureuse la mienne le
fut mais avec ces épreuves de la vie que
toute famille doit surmonter
alors ces cicatrices je ne vous en
parlerai pas parce qu'elles
n'appartiennent qu'à moi et au mien
normalement ce moment là lorsqu'on
évoque les attaques personnelles dont on
a été victimes dont ses proches ont été
victimes dont sa famille a été dit il
normalement la voix chance et ça qui est
frappant dans le discours de valérie
pécresse il n'y a jamais vraiment un
grain de voix qui fait qu' on changerait
complètement de registre et on se
parlera est naturellement comme on se
parleraient autour d'un verre mais au
moment où elle dit le mot pudeur qui est
un mot que l'on murmure normalement tu
es bien elle va lui hurler avec cette
peter je ne transigerai pas et là où en
réalité ce discours de l'impression d'un
malaise c'est me semble-t-il dans ce
qu'on appelle lé éclatera les claptrap
c'est donc en français des pièges
applaudissements et c'est un grand
classique du miti pour les respectera
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand le rappeur va appeler des
applaudissements de la foule et là chez
valérie pécresse comme elle ne va pas au
bout de ses claptrap en réalité elle en
a le texte mais on a elle n'en a pas les
intensités les intentions sur le moment
et donc ça apparaît un peu le fades et
malgré tout comme la foule comprend
qu'elle avoue à des applaudissements à
tout moment là elle va les lui donner
mais avec un décalage dans le temps cap
un essai lhimer
est donc ya pas de naturel non plus du
côté de la foule qui sent que on
l'appelle applaudissements à peu forcer
et ça c'est toujours gênant et en plus
on voit immédiatement si ça marche aussi
ça marche pas un clap rap si ça marche
dans le quart de seconde et
applaudissements surgissent tu es là
parfois il ya eu deux trois secondes et
elle laisse en plus c'est une de trois
secondes et là on voit bien que la
police mans qui est aurait dû surgir en
réalité elle est obligée de l'attendre
[Applaudissements]